updates on the president as he wakes up
in a Maryland hospital after being
diagnosed with Corona virus the
president was flown to the Walter Reed
National military Medical Center last
night in what the White House called an
abundance of caution Mr Trump is said to
be doing well despite being fatigued and
having a low-grade fever his treatment
comes as more members of his inner
circle also test positive for Co
overnight we learned president Trump's
former a kellyanne Conway and his
campaign manager Bill steppan have been
infected they joined two members of the
Senate Judiciary Committee first lady
Melania Trump GOP chair R McDaniel and
longtime Aid hope Hicks this morning
there is renewed scrutiny of a White
House Rose Garden ceremony most of this
group appeared without wearing masks at
the president's announcement one week
ago of Amy Cony Barrett as his nominee
for the Supreme Court chip Reed begins
our coverage this morning he's at Walter
Reed chip good morning to
you well good morning the White House
released a statement overnight from the
president's doctor saying he is doing
well and quote that he did not require
any supplemental oxygen the statement
also said the president is now being
treated with REM Desir which has
shortened the recovery period for some
coid 19 patients and the President also
tweeted for the first time since he
arrived here he said going well I think
thank you to all
love
president Trump arrived at Walter Reed
at 6:30 Friday night less than 24 hours
after testing positive for coid
19 earlier he walked out of the White
House wearing a mask as he headed to
Marine 1 for the short flight White
House Press Secretary Kaylee mcanany
said the move was done out of an
abundance of caution and at the
recommendation of his physician and
medical experts the president will be
working from the presidential offices at
Walter Reed for the next few days before
departing the White House the president
taped this video message I'm going to
Walter Reed hospital I think I'm doing
very well but we're going to make sure
that things work out in a statement the
president's physician Dr Shan Conley
said he was given an infusion of
regeneron antibody cocktail an
experimental coid treatment which has
shown promising results in some clinical
trials the president and first lady were
d diagnosed after one of the president's
closest AIDS hope Hicks tested positive
on Thursday for Corona virus we're
rounding the turn Hicks had been on the
road with the president who traveled to
five States during a busy week of
campaign events including Tuesday
night's debate mcenany claimed White
House officials authorized the
president's travel Thursday to a New
Jersey fundraiser where he met with
dozens of donors White House operations
made the assessment it was safe for the
president and consultation with others
now White House medical staff are
scrambling to identify those who might
have had contact with Mr Trump I fully
expect uh that as this virus continues
to go on other people in the white house
will certainly uh uh uh have a a
positive test result and uh we've got
the mitigation uh plan in place to make
sure here at Walter Reed the president
is staying in an enormous medical Suite
with all the medical bells and whistles
it's been described to us as a mini
hospital and a home away from home
Michelle all righty chip thank you so
much